the Joe Rogan experience so what what
changes have been made since you go from
the old shuttle model of that technology
to the SpaceX dragon crew thing probably
the single biggest changes is all the
we've gotten a lot better at electronics
and software so the vehicle is highly
automated and that's why we can fly like
like normal people that don't have like
years and years of training because it's
so much more smarter than the shuttle
the shuttle shouldn't say so much more
smarter so much butter but you're such a
genius you're not supposed to use
language like that you're goddamn
astronaut so much more smarter yeah you
know I'm sorry though I was a math as
those my thing that verbal my verbal
SATs weren't that spectacular about the
you know yeah this is much more smarter
and what about what about the there was
always an issue with the tiles right
with the re-entry times I was like and
then that's that's what did Challenger
and know which one was Olivia Columbia
that's what did Colombian the the new
design have they made advances and how
that stuff is applied or is it a
different surface they use yeah so that
is something that's also not really
worry anymore that the reason that
Columbia took that damage was it was
foam like the big orange tank that's
behind the Space Shuttle it sticks up
above the space shuttle and some foam
fell off of it
we always had some foam shedding off the
thing and in the beginning we took that
very very seriously as a major problem
but the thing is is this there's this
concept of of mm I'm gonna forget the
name of it now well let me just describe
it so so you get away with something for
so long that you begin it's not
normalization of deviance that's what
it's called
so it's when you get away with something
for so much so long and it's something
that was a deviant thing or something
that was bad it's treated as a normal
thing and that's what happened to us
because we knew that that foam coming
off could do damage to the space shuttle
and in the beginning we tried really
hard to do something about it we treat
very seriously but it was hard we
couldn't really come up with an easy fix
and the meantime were flying and nothing
bad was happening what was really
happening is we're getting lucky and
then eventually a big piece came off hit
Columbia right in the wing and it
shattered a minute big hole inside the
wing but nobody knew for sure and they
made a bad decision to not like
investigate it further assumed it was
okay
brought him home and and obviously you
know what happened so it could be
possible to fix something like that if
they had known it could have been
possible we did a lot of things like
when I flew we had a lot of things in
place that to try to fix that one we got
a rid of a lot of the foam that was
unnecessary we tried to do things that
stopped the foam we also had ways of
detecting it so that we would know we
had sensors and the wings we added a
maneuver we do when we fly up to the
space station we did like a pitch over
where we took photographs of the of the
heat shield to see if anything got hit
hmm so at least we would know and then
we could we could shelter in place on
the space station so there's a lot of
things we can do with the shuttle but
tonight the thing about with Dragon and
sand Starliner and the new vehicles as
they sit on top so there's no any any
foam that comes off the rocket is not
gonna hit you
so problem solved so that that's one
example of how we don't have to worry
about that anymore now is the surface
different do they still have the same
kind of tiles the the heat shield is
what it looks like again the heat shield
is that the material on the side of the
caps on the walls of the capsule is is
made out of silica so it's it's similar
to the tiles but the the material that's
in the in the heat shield itself is an
ablative material it means it kind of
like as it heats up it flakes off and it
takes the heat away with it and that's
that's kind of more similar to like it
was during Apollo it's a much more
advanced that thing yeah and they're
cool can we see that could we go there
will they give us a tour I bet we can I
bet we could my bailiff although I don't
want to see a spaceship the guy you
should ask was my boss when he was here
yeah we're talking about other [ __ ] I
know
I you know he's got the keys to the
factory but but there there she is on
the launch pad so that white stuff at
the top on the capsule itself that's
kind of like the same material as the as
the time as the tiles but the heat shown
on the bottom is called pica phenolic
impregnated carbon ablator
so it's a different it's a different
very high-tech material that is really
really good at withstanding tremendous
amounts of that heat shield is way
oversized you could use that thing at
least 10 times and it really was
originally designed for actually entries
coming back from the moon when you go in
much faster and you hit you build up a
lot more heat when you hit the
atmosphere think just coming back from
the space station so ultimately that's
the goal for these things to take people
to the moon to take people to Mars to
take people well and reusable right this
is just a start so reusability is key
and there's elements of this vehicle
that are not reusable that trunk you see
the thing the cylinder below the capsule
is not reusable we throw that away that
the second stage on the Falcon 9 we
throw away and you know Elon hates that
with that the Holy Grail is 100%
reusable but affordable reusability
where you don't have to spend like a
gazillion dollars refurbishing it in
between flights mm-hmm and we're getting
there in the next vehicle is going to be
the real that's gonna be the real
hopefully we will we will get that Holy
Grail with this starship that that we're
working on now so there's a is a
top-secret one that you can't talk about
that what it does you seem hesitant well
it's just you know we got a lot of
development going on and and it's not
top secret I mean Elon went and did a
press conference in front of it in Texas
not too long ago and showed what it
looked like yes this is one of the tests
it's called star hopper so this was a
beginning this is a test bed to test the
engine to make sure that we can that's
fake
that's real that's rude that is come on
that is not CGI really that's the thing
that's the thing
whoa now the real thing is gonna look
just like that it's it's it's the this
is really testing the engine and the
sensors and the electronics what is the
jet
the bottom those are there's that that
the bottom is a is there as a raptor
engine it's burning liquid methane and
liquid oxygen and then there's puffs at
the top are cold gas thrusters just to
keep it pointing in the right way and so
that's landing now yeah my god that's
amazing
awesome that is a mate look how gently
it lands yeah dude that seems like
science fiction I know that's not
telling you like this thing and I know
that the guys up in Blue Origin that
Jeff Bezos company has got all kinds of
incredible stuff on their drawing board
2020 is this start but it's just a start
show me that again I need to see that
again I need to see other pictures of it
okay that's that I want to see that
thing land again that video of it
landing is crazy I got lucky
did you it's so crazy though the image
to see it gently come down and perfectly
land like look at that man that looks
like some War of the Worlds type [ __ ]
like that's in a Tom Cruise movie right
yeah like if they were flying over earth
and they were starting to land my god
that's amazing
I remember when when Elin first talked
about landing Rockets on their tails he
was like I think I remember him saying
yeah we want to do it just like Buck
Rogers so I'm working with with with Ron
Moore on this TV show I'm working on now
Wow look at that thing I mean yeah
that's pretty awesome I said before
people want to see this Jimmy what is
the name of the the video so people
listening can go 50 meters starboard
tests 150 meters star hopper test more
than two million eight hundred thousand
seven hundred thousand degrees that's
amazing man two million eight hundred
ninety-eight Wow it's on the SpaceX page
so you can go check that out so that's
next stage that's net stakes so there's
gonna be a rocket and then that that
thing is gonna sit on top of it or
something like that thing and then we're
gonna get both back the rocket will land
on its tail and then after it goes off
to the moon or even Mars it'll come back
and also Landau's tail and then we'll
get both pieces will get 100% back Wow
and then we really got reusability
[Applause]